[Music]
and sugar daddy news hmm
submitted by OCD clean nice seeking
arrangements calm has ranked the top ten
universities for the number of students
using sugar daddies to pay for tuition
that's cool no that's really great
everybody wins that's dope that they're
using you for their education everybody
wins
wait so college students are using
seating arrangements to find sugar dyes
to pay for their tuition sugar daddies
and sugar mamas Oh sugar mamas good one
too sugar mommies actually sugar daddies
and sugar mommy are these top ten
universities Brigham Young USC okay Ron
UC Riverside ELAC IPC Brigham Young lund
their Santa Barbara State University
Dame none of those okay no wait
Fullerton
Chelsea Fullerton exes University of
North Texas number nine whoa I believes
in that huh uh they can't afford number
one is Georgia State University number
two is University of Central Florida
number three is University of Alabama
numbers Forrest Florida State University
number five University of Florida so
rich I've never heard somebody call
riches you've never watched college
football ever in your life I don't watch
sports fine
Florida is full of those those retired
rich people that's gonna see the other
heart word oh yeah and they have money
to spread around to the sugar babies or
whatever such a full of retired
[Music]
are you the new jersey how about that
yeah you've been we've been friends with
New Brunswick Rutgers what good luck
girls they hate us go up to the whole
school tip says whatever school okay so
number six was that one I'm not even
gonna try anymore
number seven is Cal State Fullerton
number eight University of Nevada Las
Vegas number nine is North Texas number
ten is Missouri University of Missouri
Oh what and then do you want me to say
that we get it people sucking big for
tuitions young girl I think you know the
girl swear to God no they want [ __ ] a
lot of times they want like my
girlfriend who's an escort they want
just the company companionship a notion
that's even weirder to me
I'm like at Lisa Andy you know that you
want to [ __ ] the guys who just want
someone to sit with she had paid
thousands to lay around smoke weed and
watch Game of Thrones with the dude all
right I'm not complaining for me kid
yeah probably but isn't that weird cuz
then after she leaves he still has a
jackoff well but some people just don't
want sex doing have you guys heard that
really sad story about this one s course
she had this guy that hit her up he said
hey I'll pay you if you come over can
you please come hungry she's like I'll
god this guy's into some weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] so she comes and he's cooking her
dinner and they have dinner and just ate
he's like I just wanted company cuz my
wife died and I used to love cooking for
her
allow these people actually do that sick
fun just went on the wrong website that
website well who else it like if he
doesn't have friends so whatever could
you go to friends comm instead of
hookers cheaper it would have been way
better conversational we had a [ __ ]
giraffe this for my wife she got the
longest [ __ ] nails on earth - can you
pass the water please don't even do
anything sexual what companionship
because there's a lot of lonely people
out there it's a lot longer are a lot of
lonely people on seeking arrangements to
have their variants write the jingle
thank you
I always forget you can sing he looks
like he looks like a mouth breather when
you guys were talking about mouthpieces
a little just fine thank you how much
how much is left a lot of time yeah very
quiet another four weeks of [ __ ] spy
Star Wars tickets as you're sitting here
just like this I want I really went like
this I want tongue to roof now anyway so
they have this student debt clock and
they're saying that it's one point six
billion dollars right now they are
saying they're trying to have more
people join just like nationally us yeah
that's crazy they're trying
have people joined the 2.7 million
students in the United States who have
turned to seeking arrangements and sugar
daddies to avoid student debt and secure
a better future so that's like a
marketing plan you know a [ __ ] up the
student loan system is where my sister
has a loan and the feds make money off
of her lump like the government provided
the loan and they make their making yeah
they haven't profit off of it and you
know it's sad she doesn't pay it she can
go to jail yeah you know what sucks too
is almost all debt and loans if you file
bankruptcy you're clear from that except
for student loan exactly as soon as you
come back they're still getting their
money the government figured out a way
to make it legal for them to make a
profit off of student loans unbelievable
what a system it's expensive to be
educated out here but then nobody ever
[ __ ] like hey why don't the
universities like lower tuition nobody
ever says that should be at most eight
thousand a year like where do they come
up with this price I don't know cuz it's
not like we're fighting books and it's
not like that you pay for your own good
and select the teachers getting paid a
[ __ ] ton of money
and it's not like the education is twice
as good yeah it's like the same as
before but then they go up every year
and it's like hey yeah they're saying
that the amount that students own the
u.s. quadrupled from 2004 to 2007 teen
and so now a lot of students are turning
to these types of websites to pay off
their loans
damn it should you know what they have
to do that you know I mean like that
because education is so expensive but
it's [ __ ] awesome that they're also
doing it yeah are we high right now I
feel like I'm high as Harry oh don't
talk to me they claim that they have 1.9
million
sugar daddies 356,000 sugar mommy's
eight eight point three million sugar
baby females and three million sugar
baby males you have to be a really
confident person to say somebody wants
to pay me money yep so I could just be
there yeah that's some confidence too
because I don't have that crap look at
Instagram chick confidence bro yeah
that's straight up what is it I know
you want to pay for cuz I'm not gonna
take the risk of signing up to be one of
these little sugar things and nobody
gets me up because that's gonna hit Mike
off but it's so bad
could you flash it up bad oh yeah good
like you're sitting there like I'm gonna
pay for my tuition yeah
not a single ding know though like
they'll pay for half of your in and out
orders yeah like we'll get the fries
that's it that's pretty good I wonder
what you guys can get because of your
what's the word I'm looking for
vanity that value or just this beauty
yeah status out of ten challenge talent
what if the author let's sign up and see
what happens
oh there's no touching none of that [ __ ]
it's just conversation and going out to
you dude there's this girl that I know
she there's a her friend gets paid to go
on a date this guy to be his beard cuz
he doesn't want his family to know that
he's gay so she gets paid five hundred
all his per date just to be tend to be
his girlfriend that's pretty good like
the whole time she's touchy was like
this she has monetized him being in the
closet and then when they're at dinner
she's like oh you don't need to come out
your parents will never understand you
they might kick you out what does he do
for a living mmm beard also work for a
lesbian lady that was his word for that
beard and uh fluff lesbian truck yeah
yeah it's pretty you'll find to get a
lot of searches you get a lot of his
boyfriend for lesbian term okay bowling
shirts hi beard faux faux beau I guess
if you're doing hormone replacement you
can grow a beard how's it go again
oh nice I've also seen people with no
hormone replacement just had beer
straight up I've seen that too a lot of
older ladies whiskers
see teacher that she definitely shaved
easy as double 2099 ranch and a lady had
a full semester
doing it 99 right being lost spending
two and a half hours looking for a
single ingredient how about that word
for Nikki's but for Nikki's tasty chili
I gotta go there I gotta try to figure
out what the [ __ ] is going on everything
is written in babel fish find one
ingredient just one and I go up to a guy
on my hey can you help me he's like I
can't find anything no she's busy with
prepping for tasty Tuesdays at cutting
carrots and [ __ ] she's like can you do
this I'm stressing out I'm like okay
sure and then it takes me like you know
a Lord of the Rings movie amount of time
to [ __ ] look through this grocery
store and find one I'm looking for plain
it's just a bunch of constants and
vowels matter together
[Music]